bad robots relationship with Warner
Brothers has been a little Rocky and
that LEDs to the possibility that they
might move over to MGM and they might
make Stargate
but it looks like the danger has passed
Will Robinson
welcome to Scythe check your Sci-Fi TV
and movie channel
[Music]
so I told you a couple of months ago
actually that I found out what the pitch
idea was for Stargate the Bad Robot was
suggesting and we generally hated it
they were gonna bring back Wrath
what made no sense they were going to
maybe bring back Kurt Russell what made
no sense and they were going to make
this Standalone movie that was very much
connected to the original Stargate
rather than the TV series what which
also made no sense we universally agreed
that we did not like this idea and that
we did not want bad robot anywhere near
Stargate but why were they actually
pitching this idea because they actually
do have an exclusivity deal with Warner
Brothers that runs through until next
year I dare you to step over this line
okay almost happened well that Warner
Brothers deal has been a little bit
shaky of late the relationship between
JJ Abrams and Bad Robot and Warner
Brothers particularly since the new
people have come in and David zaslav Etc
have took over has been not great I dare
to step over this one
this one now actually they have this
exclusivity deal a five-year deal and
were paid 250 million dollars as part of
that agreement and they were supposed to
be making television series and movies
now they haven't actually produced
anything up to now
[Music]
all of the projects they've put forwards
have either been completely rejected or
have got stuck in development hell and
four years nearly into this agreement
they have done and NADA
this one
now that's not completely their fault
let's not forget that literally within
six months of signing this agreement we
all went down into a pandemic and a
lockdown but we have moved on from that
right so why are they still not
producing anything
well they did have a couple of DC
projects on the go those have been uh
canceled very quietly by James Gunn so
they're not happening
Superman Project black Superman Project
I believe it was called and a couple of
animated Batman series was supposed to
get done at the moment it doesn't look
like they are they were supposed to be
doing a Speed Racer series for apple and
that kind of is stuck in developmental
as well
but there has been a little bit of a
change MGM movies was actually headed up
by Michael Deluca and Pam Abdi now they
moved over to Warner Brothers very early
on after the sale went through Amazon
pretty much pushed them out pretty
quickly they were apparently promised
lots and lots of things during the sale
but as soon as it was actually finalized
by the FTC those promises were reneged
on and Pam Abdi and Michael DeLuca then
left and went over to Warner Brothers
I know that look
you're not getting any younger
this isn't good for your back
I brought this on myself
now a key for Goldman's weed Road
production company is following them now
they've had a deal with MGM for movies
and TV for the last few years but
actually Akiva Goldman worked with
Warner Brothers for about 20 years
before that so for him it is a going
home but he has followed Pam Abdi and
Michael Deluca and made a big point of
saying about following them across and
how happy is to get to work with them
again now as part of that he is going to
be doing an I Am Legend sequel with Will
Smith and Michael B Jordan that's going
to be interesting I'm really looking
forward to that if they recapture the
tone of the original that could be a
very exciting zombie movie I don't
particularly like zombie movies I find
them a little boring generally but I am
Legend really stands out for me as
Summit a little bit different
also though he has finally agreed and
got Warner Brothers to agree to make
Constantine too with Keanu Reeves now
this is a project that Keanu Reeves has
been begging for literally every year I
read him in a interview just a couple of
weeks ago and he says literally every
year he'll go and go Constantine two
please please please and they go no
Constantine too and he goes ah go on no
no no so he just Waits 12 months and
goes back in and asks again
but finally thanks to Akiva moving over
to Warner Brothers and him getting
behind the project it looks like
Constantine 2 is in very early
development and has been green lit but
why does this help us with Bad Robot
because bad robots are going to be
producing the movie
yes
yes yes yes yes yes
they're going to be producing
Constantine too which is a shame I will
admit but silver lining it means to deal
with Warner Brothers isn't going to
collapse like it looked like it was now
there is still Rumblings of them getting
sued by Warner Brothers because they
have not produced anything
this one
and they might kind of want a bit of
their 250 million dollars back but if JJ
Abrams can get working and actually
produce something it would be very
difficult for Warner Brothers to take
legal action however I have also heard
of Rumblings that if this deal is
extended it will not be anything like as
favorable and will be more based around
actual what they produce rather than a
large initial fee so let's see what
happens in the next 12 months but this
strengthening and rebuilding of the
relationship between JJ Abrams Bad Robot
and Warner Brothers is good for us
because we do not want bad robots
anywhere near Stargate
so it looks like that possibility is now
dead Aunt JJ Abrams a Bad Robot thought
that this deal was going to collapse
they started throwing ideas out like
this Stargate movie and like Star Trek 4
another movie they couldn't actually do
anyway because of this exclusivity deal
but really just prove what I'm talking
about how they genuinely believed this
contract was going to collapse so guys
what do you think are you happy about
this news or are you a little bit
disappointed they're going to be making
Constantine too a film personally I
adored the original and I cannot wait
for the sequel and I'm really happy
Keanu Reeves is going to be doing it but
what do you think get into the comments
celebration or with a tingy
disappointment
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and if
you want to become a fully fledged side
tracker and really support the channel
consider hitting the join button also
there are loads of links in the
description to everything Sidetrack
related our Discord server Twitter
um nine Chevrons our Stargate website
and so on and so on and so on so please
go and check those
as always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
[Music]